sergei lavrov sagte wir greifen die
ukraine nicht an paul und bei dir gibt
es schon wieder sirenenalarm
thomas gerade eben dreimal sirenenalarm
hier in kiew und es ist ein völliger
wahnsinn was der russische
aussenminister dort sagt wie erlebe
diesen krieg hier seit mehr als zwei
wochen ich habe die zerstörung gesehen
gesehen wo raketen eingeschlagen sind
zerstörte häuser wir haben mit opfern
des krieges gesprochen hier ist krieg in
der ukraine
und das ist wirklich nur noch an
zynismus es ist an zynismus wirklich
nicht mehr zu überbieten was der
russische außenminister da von sich gibt
und wenn wir uns die situation rund um
kiew anschauen dann muss man davon
ausgehen dass dadurch dass die
verhandlungen gescheitert sind jetzt
möglicherweise der nächste schlag
ansteht und wir haben diese dramatischen
bildern mario pohl gesehen von einem
kinderkrankenhaus
wir erwarten dass wladimir putin seine
truppen weiter hier richtung verschickt
und die stadt einzeln einkesseln will
paul wir können sogar während wir
sprechen noch grausamere bilder zeigen
die die ganze wirklichkeit abbilden dort
in mario pohl wo nicht mal mehr zeit ist
die leichen richtig zu begraben in
einzelnen gräbern sondern in
massengräbern müssen sie verscharrt
werden das ist die bittere bittere
grausame wahrheit die dort unten
stattfindet
das ist die realität des krieges thomas
eines grausamen krieges eines putin
kriegs gegen die menschen hier in der
ukraine
und dass sich ein außenminister sergej
lawrow auf der sehr gut englisch spricht
dessen verwandte in new york gelebt
haben der überall in der welt
herumgekommen ist dass der tatsächlich
diese propaganda weiter vertritt und
wladimir putins lügen mit vertritt er
wird sich irgendwann dafür verantworten
müssen hoffentlich paulis lag ja so
unglaublich viel hoffnung auf diesen
verhandlungen auf diesen friedensgipfel
der jetzt absolut gar keinen
friedensgipfel war was glaubst du wie
geht das jetzt weiter werden wird es in
den nächsten tagen noch mal gespräche
geben
also mir war ohnehin klar dass es dort
heute kein ergebnis geben wird das wäre
zu schnell und ein ergebnis kann es nur
dann geben wenn sie lenski und putin
miteinander sprechen das hat der
ukrainische präsident auch gestern bei
mir im interview gesagt und er hat ja
auch gesagt er ist bereit für
kompromisse allerdings müsse auch putin
bereits sein für kompromisse und von
seinen maximalforderungen so kann man
das ja kaum nennen wenn er sagt dass die
ukraine gar nicht existiert sondern eben
teil russlands ist also von der von der
forderung dass der ukraine dass die
ukraine kein souveräner staat ist runter
kommen muss denn wie soll der präsident
eines souveränen staates ist darüber
verhandeln dass es schier unmöglich
allerdings glaube ich dass es jetzt auch
nicht so ist dass diese verhandlungen
für immer gescheitert sind das war jetzt
ein anfang ohne echtes ergebnis ja das
ist richtig aber der ukrainische
aussenminister hat ja auch gesagt dass
er weiter bereit ist zu sprechen oder
dass es gespräche geben soll und im
hintergrund wird dort weiterverhandelt
also der präsidentenberater jeder mag
der mit dem präsidenten unterwegs ist
der hat mir auch gestern im präsidenten
gebäude gesagt dass er ständig in
kontakten dort ist mit verschiedenen
ländern aber natürlich auch versucht man
mit der russischen seite weiter zu
sprechen und je nach dem je nach der
militärischen lage auch hier in kiew um
kiew wird sich das weiterentwickeln
paula hat auch indirekte gedroht den
europäern er hat gesagt es sei sehr
gefährlich dass die europäer waffen an
die ukraine liefern würden wir russland
bedroht in dem die ukraine aufrüstet der
muss wissen was er tut und auf die frage
eines russischen journalisten und das
sollte man dazu erwähnen man kann davon
ausgehen dass diese frage abgesprochen
war glauben sie dass ein atomkrieg
möglich ist sagt er ich möchte nicht
daran glauben
ja frau fährt dort auch die strategie
des angst der angst der panik die ja bei
uns auslösen will bei all den menschen
die das sehen bei den menschen in
deutschland die sich sorgen machen um
ihr land um ihren ort darum ob wladimir
putin möglicherweise noch weiter gehen
will und allein dass er darüber spricht
und diese drohungen ausspricht oft er
das ist druck gibt sozusagen aus der
bevölkerung gegenüber der deutschen
politik zu sagen hört auf waffen zu
liefern hört auf die ukraine zu
unterstützen um dann am ende dafür zu
sorgen dass die russische armee hier
kiew ein kessel kann und möglicherweise
einnehmen kann also das ist die
strategie die aus meiner sicht dahinter
steht paule du hast uns auch die info
gegeben dass die lenski morgen im
bundesrat gesprächen wird was es davon
zu erwarten
der ukrainische präsident hat ja schon
vor mehreren parlamenten gesprochen hat
vor dem europäischen parlament
gesprochen er hat auch in großbritannien
vor dem parlament gesprochen alles
natürlich per videoschalte ist klar und
das gleiche wird jetzt im bundesrat
passieren dort sind die
ministerpräsidenten versammelt und
velodrome lenski wird dort eine
ansprache halten an die
ministerpräsidenten und wird erneut
davon gehe ich aus einem dramatischen
appell an deutschland an die deutsche
politik richten dass mehr passieren muss
dass es eben gesagte anfangs unserer
schalte dass es wieder mehrfach
luftalarm in kiew gab und ja ich muss es
immer wieder fragen aber was erwartest
du für diesen tag heute für die
hauptstadt
ich gehe davon aus das hat sich auch in
meinen gesprächen ergeben dass es
weitere versuche der russischen armee
gibt insbesondere in den vororten wir
haben in den vergangenen tagen viel über
ihre pin und guter gesprochen das sind
die orte wo es heftige kämpfe gibt und
aus allen seiten wird versucht weiter
richtung hier vor zu kommen und hier die
wege abzuschneiden möglicherweise könnte
sich das ganze weiter eskalieren durch
die tatsache dass es keine aufgabe der
ukraine bislang gibt und auch keine
ergebnisse bei den diskutierten
friedensverhandlungen euro und zweimal
in kiew vielen dank paul